from Gucci - Chanel Topshop - Primark
clothes industry heavyweights rely on
fashion forecasters the next season's
new look but advancements in artificial
intelligence are about to turn their art
into a science cognitive computing is
now able to identify patterns previously
inaccessible to humans it can
simultaneously analyze vast amounts of
global data from social media buzz to
political polls making it possible to
accurately spot what's hot and what's
not WGSN the world's biggest fashion
forecaster now uses AI alongside more
traditional methods a move that could
reduce forecasting errors by up to 50%
trend-spotting mistakes can have
far-reaching consequences H&M recently
confessed to a 4.3 billion dollar unsold
stock mountain industry waste costs both
profits and reputation technology could
make the fashion industry more
sustainable by using machine learning
and AI technique to match supply with
demand unnecessary manufacturing could
be limited and fashions environmental
footprint reduce online retailers our
crop Milan in the next two years 75% of
fashion retailers plan to invest in AI
but keeping up with tech giants is going
to be tough
Amazon is now developing what's believed
to be the world's first AI fashion
designer it plans to use an algorithm
that designs clothes by analyzing images
and copying popular styles using them to
build completely new designs this
technological makeover could hold huge
benefits especially for those who like
to shop online a Japanese company has
unveiled the Zozo a body measurement
suit that will ensure the clothes you
order fits you perfectly
all meaning our future wardrobes could
contain clothes designed for us and sold
to us by technology alone
you